Happy birthday dear mom. Happy birthday to you.
Good morning, John. It's Friday, March 16th.
Today is an important day for
Brotherhood 2.0 for more than
one reason. A significant importance to
Brotherhood 2.0 is ZeFrank, who
likely inspired a lot of what
we're doing here. Maybe even a little bit
more than we realized sometimes.
ZeFrank has made a hilarious video every
weekday for the past year. By doing this
he has garnered international attention
in publication in the New York Times and
a viewership of hundreds of thousands. We
would like to be as popular as ZeFrank
but we will never be. Because we aren't
anywhere near as cool as ZeFrank. But
starting today, that doesn't matter
anymore. ZeFrank viewers won't be able
to watch ZeFrank anymore. Thus, I think ZeFrank viewers maybe should come
check out the Brotherhood. Welcomes
ZeFrank viewers. Any of you out there? Isn't
it gonna be a horrible life without
having ZeFrank to procrastinate with?
You can procrastinate with us. I mean we
blink. ZeFrank doesn't blink. We write
songs though but they're not as good as ZeFrank songs. And we have projects that
our viewers can participate in with us.
But none of them are anywhere near as
cool as making the entire world of
sandwich. Second reason that this is a
very important day for Brotherhood 2.0
is because there is only one
person who is vital to the creation of
the Brotherhood and that is our mom.
Actually today isn't mom's birthday.
Tomorrow is mom's birthday but tomorrow,
it's Saturday. There won't be
any Brotherhood 2.0 in tomorrow.
So I'm taking the opportunity to
celebrate mom's birthday a day early on
Brotherhood 2.0. Now there
really is no one who's more important
Brotherhood 2.0 than our mom. I
mean we both came out of her and I
really and truly want to thank her for
that. I know it must not have been very
fun. I have a pretty big head and I guess
it didn't really get all that much
easier for you. I mean that first day was
bad
and then there were probably some bad
days pretty soon after that. And I know there
were some bad days a few years after
that and then high school was like, all
bad days and then I'm at the college and
I just never called you. Oh. Happy
birthday mom. Having kids kind of sucks.
But I hope you know that they appreciate
you. Your support has been vital. This
might seem a little bit stupid or
callous or maybe even inhuman but I
think you should be able to own stock in
people. So for example when a child is
born, the parents have a minority stake
in the interests of the child whereas
the child would own a full 51% of itself,
the parents would only own 49. The child
could never sell its majority stake but
the parents could sell their minority
stake to different people. Like when the
kid goes off to college, the parents
could sell like ten percent of the kid
to the college and that way the college
can get something back from the kid for
what it gives to the kid. And then later
the kid might want to buy some of his
stock back from you. So he'll have more
than a 51-percent stake in his self.
Knowing my mom, she'd probably just give
me that forty-nine percent and I don't a
hundred percent of myself. But it seems
somehow wrong that people can put so
much energy into a person and then that
person gets to take all that energy and
do whatever they want with it. Mom,
shouldn't you be getting something back?
You invested a lot of time and effort
and worry and discomfort in me. And I
feel bad that I just have all that stuff
that you gave me and I can do whatever I
want with it. I guess what I'm trying to
say is moms are great and they do it all
for nothing. I'll see you on Monday.
And if the world were a sandwich, we
could all be one sandwich.